let's talk about turkey and why it could
be at a turning point
for the last 20 years this man reject
Tai erdogan has been running the country
he's this huge political figure someone
who's inspired a lot of support and a
lot of criticism
the country is deeply divided and
elections are coming up which could be
erdogan's biggest test yet it's a kind
of take it or leave it or Make It or
Break It kind of moments opposition
parties have United behind one candidate
to take on erdogan the opposition picked
maybe it's least charismatic candidate
but the one that also checks boxes in
terms of getting the support of a wide
cross-section of society so what exactly
is the choice voters are facing why is
the opposition looking stronger than it
has in a long time
and remember turkey is still dealing
with the aftermath of those devastating
earthquakes so how might that affect the
vote
foreign
[Music]
on May 14th people in Turkey will vote
for a president and a new Parliament
more on that later in the presidential
contest erdogan the current president is
up against Kamal kilich darolu they're
the two main candidates now it takes 50
percent of the vote plus one to win
otherwise it'll go to a second round and
this is why it's important to make
political alliances erdogan's got his
awk party and the Nationalist MHP on
site plus another smaller party that's
the People's Alliance kilichterolu is
the leader of the main opposition party
the CHP and he's got the support of five
other parties they make up the nation
Alliance some people refer to this
Coalition as a table of six there are
leftist parties there are right-wing
parties islamist parties nationalist
parties together
now is the candidate of this unified
opposition he's been in politics a long
time and has actually run against
erdogan three times before but is always
lost
is the antithesis of president erdogan
while President erdogan has this Macho
way of ruling is more self-spoken he's a
sort of compromising figure but this is
what he is positioning as his strength
he says that the country is too divided
and that he would be the uniter now to
understand turkey's divisions we need to
look at the bigger picture
turkey has always been shaped by its
unique location right between Europe and
the Middle East
the vast majority of people are Muslim
but secularism this idea of separating
religion from state is one of the main
principles of turkey's Constitution
that goes back a hundred years to when
the modern state of turkey was
established by Mustafa Kemal Ataturk an
Ataturk wanted the country to have more
of a western Outlook and brought in
European style secularism
but over time it also led to a situation
where many conservative and religious
people felt really marginalized and
excluded from public life for example
for many years women weren't allowed to
wear headscarves in government offices
or universities
but things changed when the awk party
came onto the scene it was founded by
erdogan in the late 1990s it's a
conservative party with roots in
political Islam
the ACT party swept to power in the
early 2000s and erdogan became prime
minister
it was the start of a new political era
I think throughout the 90s and 2000s the
primary driving force in Turkish
politics was the secular versus
conservative divide
the old camelist ideology which was
staunchly secular and in some sense
tried to push out conservative and
islamist politics versus erdogan who
promised not just a place for
conservatives in turkey and its
political and public space but also said
he would do it in a democratic framework
now that's secular versus conservative
divide still exists in many ways but it
doesn't necessarily translate into a
political Choice as clearly or
predictably as it used to secularists
are no longer the the the hard-line
chemists that they used to be excluding
a conservatives from public space or or
from politics and that shift is clearer
than ever in this election where for
example you have secularists and
religious conservatives teaming up in
killidge dorolu's Coalition this may
makes things harder for erdogan even
though he's still got a strong base
around 30 percent of the population who
will probably vote for him no matter
what there is a large constituency here
in Turkey which is quite happy with our
dog and he they think that if he leaves
the power
they will also lose their gains everyone
has a very committed base but that's
being shrinking Turkish conservatives do
not blindly vote for AKP anymore and
that's also where other issues come into
play like the economy which is tanking
now during his early years in power
erdogan really transformed the economy
and that was part of his appeal in the
2000s there was an economic boom that
lifted many into the middle classes
erdogan also revalued turkey's currency
which helped to bring Decades of high
inflation under control but in the last
few years the economy has been pretty
much disastrous now the backdrop is a
range of pressures like all the security
problems because of the war in
neighboring Syria the impact of taking
in 3.6 million Syrian refugees and the
pandemic
but there's also been erdogan's decision
to prioritize cutting interest rates
which has got a lot of criticism from
economists and spooked the markets
turkey's currency the Lira has crashed
people's savings are worth just one
tenth of what they were a decade ago an
inflationist soared it's come down a bit
recently but it's still over 50 percent
year on year and everyone is feeling it
foreign
changing the life quality another big
issue in this election is Turkey's
political system itself it's why so many
people are talking about this being a
potential Turning Point
six years ago erdogan shifted turkey
from a parliamentary system to a
presidential one that was after a
referendum his argument was that a
presidential system would be more
efficient but it's not been as simple as
that the expectation was that the
decision maker process will be quite
fast but just the reverse has happened
is the sole decision maker the people
who are in government agencies avoid
taking risky decisions or important
decisions erdogan's critics also say
that this system gives him too much
power without enough checks and balances
and they accuse erdogan and his party of
undermining turkey's democracy through
things like control of the media and
weakening institutions like the
Judiciary
now if kilich starolu wins he's
promising to move turkey back to a
parliamentary system within the next few
years he's pitching it as a choice
between democracy and autocracy
Adams
there is a consensus for even among
conservatives that there is problems
right now but the question they will be
asking are the other guys going to
provide a better alternative to Turkey
so you've got a tanking economy an
intense debate about the political
system and erdogan's record and then
there's the other huge issue affecting
Turkey right now the devastation from
the earthquakes back in February
[Music]
more than 50 000 people died two million
lost their homes and cities were
destroyed many criticize the
government's initial response for being
slow and chaotic
the youngest what happens even erdogan
admitted that mistakes were made
[Music]
this is done
hello the fact that so many buildings
collapse also raised questions about the
government's enforcement of building
regulations
so naturally the question is will all of
that impact how people vote well it's
hard to know because there are reasons
why both sides could gain or lose votes
over the earthquake issue people are
really angry towards government there
are so many deaths so there will be
protests or votes against the government
much of their affected area is AKP
stronghold and there in those provinces
the government was able to come out and
say look we made mistakes on day one and
two but here we are helping you with
financial aid with tense so I think it
has the effect of making people
particularly in in those areas coalesce
around the state is
bottom line is this election could go
either way it's really unpredictable the
two main Rivals have a staunch support
base they can count on and the polls
show they're pretty close although most
put kalich derolu slightly ahead but
remember they need to pass 50 to win so
that's where a few other factors come in
there are the undecided voters they make
up around five percent and a lot could
happen before election day to swing them
one way or the other and then there's
Muharram inject another presidential
candidate who's pretty popular in the
2018 election he ran against erdogan as
the CHP candidate but has now formed his
own party he's pulling somewhere between
five and ten percent of the vote picking
up support from opposition voters who
are unimpressed by kilichterolu and see
him as Old and Out of Touch
and then there's the pro-kurdish party
the hdp which represents about 10 to 12
percent of the electorate they're not
Fielding a presidential candidate which
boosts kilichterolu's chances HTTP
support
might produce important outcomes maybe
that's the only way actually foreign
remember also that parliamentary
elections are happening on the same day
and the result of those will also be
crucial Turkish voters may decide to
split
the ticket in other words vote for
erdogan for presidency but vote for
opposition in the parliament giving them
the majority or the flip side the most
observers reckon that scenario could
make political divisions worse and
destabilize the country even more when
actually most people are desperate for
some stability after many difficult
years these are elections that could
lead to a huge political change but
whether that'll really make people's
lives better is the question most voters
will be asking themselves
is turkey better off under erdogan or in
a posterdon world
and am I better off under erdogan or
without terrible irrespective of the
final outcome the dates and months or
years ahead will be quite challenging
for Turkish people
[Music]